hello reject ville hello hello hello
Logan trailer grace to rule TV's
whopping with kids there
[Music]
[Music]
good good I'm glad it's rated R amazing
grace I wonder why they would put that
over a Super Bowl TV spot this is
Trump's America now we don't need to be
reminded of traditional values
interesting change of pace with that
music choice I mean last one first one
we got Johnny Cash is hurt then we got K
Leo's way down we go no we got the good
old American American tune we got a
couple of new imagery images here wish I
knew who the characters were pride
should have done a little more research
for filming this video you see that one
guy putting on like you know his Winter
Soldier hand souther nude who looks like
[ __ ] deform like a skinny Prometheus
character it looks like he's letting off
turn aids right now and then they showed
that x-23 wasn't running through the
forest alone that there was a bunch of
other kids there must be a lot of
children they're experimenting on in
here the mood of this movie just seems
like it's gonna really stick with you
everything's gonna be a haunting film I
feel like I'm gonna feel like a really
dark of gloomy vibe about it I'm still
it's still my most anticipated film of
the year but for some reason it's only
30 seconds long I don't think it's
better than the other full trailers that
we got watching just this small 30
seconds and looking at more images of
the villain like characters makes this
seem a lot creepier before we was all
about Logan x-23 Professor X now we got
a few more glimpses into the villains
who seem like this is gonna be pressure
to get out the grenades man he looked
like my old uncle and we got along
traumatize me a little bit we don't talk
about too much on this video today if
you're do the channel you can subscribe
to the real rejects follow me on
instagram and twitter at the gregory
alba it's actually just the greg alba i
got a lot of awesome nude pictures on
there that only guys like i never see a
girl like any of my shirtless photos
it's really sad actually but it makes
perfect sense girls don't want to you
know come on too strong they don't see
my naked body and they're like that's
just if i chase him it's just gonna be
like every other girl so i know what
you're doing you're playing hard to get
I'm not in denial about this